london's been the front line of the
omicron crisis uh huge numbers of
infections thousands of nhs and other
public service staff of sick and now the
military being sent in to support
overstretched hospitals
but it's also where we might just be
starting to see a glimmer of light at
the end of the tunnel with talk of us
reaching or even getting past the peak
of new cases and hospital admissions
let's try to find out what's happening
in the capital and what it means for the
rest of the country
professor kevin fenton is the public
health regional director for london good
morning professor fenton
good morning good morning travel
has um
the omicron wave
reached its peak in london
well we think we may have passed or are
at the peak data from the ons suggests
that the peak may have occurred at or
just about the new year period and we're
seeing reductions in overall case rates
across the city and the prevalence of
infection within the community but
remember that infection levels are still
very very high and the ons figures
suggest that nearly one in ten londoners
are still infected with the uh with the
with the disease so it means that we're
not yet out of this critical phase of
the pandemic although we may well be
past the peak
but um what we do know that you probably
have more data than anybody else um and
you can probably tell us more about
omicron itself is it correct
as people now seem to be saying that the
evidence suggests that it's milder and
that the it will come
and go faster than delta
yes i mean when we looked at the data
from south africa we saw the sort of
explosive growth and then the uh rapid
reductions in infection we're not yet
seeing the rapid reductions in infection
levels in the city but what we have seen
over the past few few weeks is that as
we've gone through the pandemic we have
seen significant numbers of people
becoming infected a lot of pressure on
our general beds
in hospitals across london but
thankfully less pressure on our icu beds
and the reason we've seen that trevor is
because of the high levels of
vaccination that we have across the city
and the most pressure that we have are
from people who are unvaccinated or
incompletely vaccinated and that's where
we're seeing the pressure on the
hospital systems and that's why we're
putting so much effort across the city
to getting people vaccinated getting
their boosters even if they haven't been
vaccinated to this point
i want to come back to this question of
um the unvaccinated in a second but
let's um just stick for a moment if we
may with the
position of the nhs um i know nobody can
absolutely predict this but is it your
feeling that london's hospitals will be
able to cope this winter
well it certainly is our hope we are
seeing a slowing down in the rate of
increase of patients with covert being
admitted to london hospitals and that's
really good news but as you said at the
top of the story there are other
pressures that we're facing currently
across our health system in the city so
for example we have relatively higher
staff sickness absence rates which some
of which are from uh covert but there
may be other respiratory illnesses which
are also causing challenges as well and
of course we have the usual winter
pressures which we see as we move
through january and february and as we
emerge from the new year period we're
seeing more people presenting to our
hospital services with a sort of heart
disease the the things that we would
normally see in the winter so there's
three things covered staff sickness
absence as well as winter pressures
means that for the hospitals in london
we're still in a critical phase
i think you've um recently
uh picked out a specific thing and said
that you're worried about the rising
number of cases amongst the over 60s in
london do you think
that's a particular issue and will it
lead to more hospitalizations and
serious cases uh of covid
yeah so that's the great point and we're
watching it really really carefully
what we've learned from waves one and
waves two is that the what's one of the
strongest predictors of your likelihood
of hospitalization is being in that over
60 age group and of course if you're
unvaccinated and as the rates are
continuing to increase in that age we're
looking really carefully at the
pressures that it's placing on our
systems
thankfully we have very high rates of
vaccination and booster coverage in our
over 60s in london so we're hoping that
even if we're seeing increasing
infections that it will translate into
significant pressures in our hospitals
and especially in icu beds and this
really is the power of the vaccinations
that we have treble because it really
does prevent severe disease and death
from omicron and all other variants of
the virus
well that takes us actually to the point
you made earlier on which is about the
unvaccinated um
for the last
six or seven months or so health
officials like yourself have been
telling us there needs to be a process
of education and so on well
actually what we're probably now seeing
is that there is a hard core of people
who say i know all about it i just don't
want to have it i mean
pierce corbin the leader of uh
the anti-vaxx movement in london is not
an uneducated man he's an astrophysicist
and uh a phd he understands the science
he just doesn't want to have it
what is your plan to deal with those who
are literally
convinced
sincere anti-vaxxers
well we must remember trevor that that
segment of the population is very very
very small the people who are sort of uh
very strong anti-vaxxer
who hold those views
for the vast majority of londoners we
know that there are three reasons why
people don't get vaccinated the first is
that you know it's an issue of
convenience and access and their ability
to navigate the system you know many
londoners may not have english as their
first language so we have to do the work
of going into communities engaging with
those
individuals and ensuring that we have
good access to the vaccines another
reason in london is that many especially
our younger people may have become
infected with the virus during the
course of the pandemic and so they may
feel less inclined to take the vaccine
because they believe they're already
protected
because they've been exposed and for
this group we're ensuring that we have
strong messages about the power of the
vaccination combined with prior
infection to help to protect you moving
forward so these are other reasons why
people aren't getting the vaccines and i
think we need to focus on those and work
with those individuals and communities
rather than trying to convince people
who are absolutely not willing to take
the vaccine
professor fenton thank you so much
thank you